we're standing in front of Shakespeare's
Globe a modern reconstruction near the
site of Shakespeare's own Globe Theatre
built in 1599 and this reconstruction
isn't it is the best way really of
getting a sense of what Shakespeare's
actual theatrical practice of his own
time would have been like it's an
open-air air theatre in the round it
accommodated up to about 3,000
spectators crowded in most of them
standing in front of the stage there was
a trestle stage that thrust out into the
crowd the crowd surrounded it and then
they were galleries so you paid a penny
to get into this theatre the money was
put in a box that's why we have the term
box office and then if you had the money
and you had another penny you could get
out of the Sun or out of the rain at
least as often and paid to be in one of
the gallery places where there was at
least a little roof over your head if
you had another penny you could get a
chair with a cushion and if you had a
lot of money
sixpence at the time that's a
substantial amount of money you could
get one of the seats behind the stage or
possibly even on the stage that were
terrible from the point of view of
seeing the play but were great in terms
of having people see the beautiful
clothes that you were wearing which
evidently was an important part of the
experience of the theatre in
Shakespeare's time the theatre had no
artificial lighting and it had no sets
of the kind with which we're familiar it
had a chair that could be brought on on
off the stage or a bed that could be
brought on on off the stage but
basically nothing like the sets that to
which we're accustomed as it had no
curtain also no illusion there's a
platform and on the platform there are
the actors who must have developed very
powerful voices as well as powerful
memories because they could speak their
plays out and be heard by two or three
thousand people in the round space the
theatre was not without some sense of
something other than simply the flat
stage because it had two columns
that held up a a kind of canopy over the
playing space the canopy over the
playing space was important for one
thing because the single most valuable
property that the players owned were
costumes these theaters paid much more
for a good costume than they played for
than they paid for a play the costumes
were valuable in themselves and they
were valuable symbolically because
especially in a stage without sets the
costumes carried huge symbolic meaning
if you wore the cloak of a nobleman if
you wore the regalia at least that could
conjure up the idea of a king or for
that matter if you wore a beautiful
dress and there were beautiful dresses
worn they were worn by an entirely male
company that means that all of the great
and minor for that matter female parts
that's the Mona philia Cleopatra the
like were played by boys they were
talented actors usually between the ages
of 12 and 20 and they were evidently
very gifted at conveying especially in
their beautiful costumes the the life
the manners the impression of women in
fact Englishmen who traveled abroad in
the late 16th and early 17th century and
went to places like Venice where they
could see actual women on stage we
marked that it was amazing how good the
women were there at at performing the
women's parts almost as good as the boy
actors in London evidently the boy
actors were very very good indeed and
the company had a big stake financially
in the costumes that they owned
hence the great pillars that rose up out
of the platform stage also provided
protection by holding a canopy over the
actors so they wouldn't have to stand
out in the rain but also there was a
another symbolic association with that
canopy which was often painted with
stars and conveyed the idea of the
heavens of
the heads of the actors just as there
was a heavens symbolically above the
stage held up by those columns so too
there was a hell below the stage that
hell was the space under the trestle
stage not visible to the crowd
surrounding the stage but accessible
through a trapdoor that could be opened
on the stage and we know that it was
used on lots of different occasions in
the theatre Shakespeare's plays and in
others most notably in Hamlet you'll
remember that Hamlet hears the ghost
moving like a mole under the stage and
he himself Hamlet moves around listening
for the ghost and the ghost indeed cries
out from below the stage swear swear you
hear the voice rising up from below the
stage or in act 5 of Hamlet when the
philia is the debt Ophelia is interred
on the ground they must have used that
space they must have opened the trapdoor
and lowered her there and indeed when
Laertes leaps into the grave in mourning
and Hamlet jumps after him to wrestle
with Laertes to try to prove who's the
most filled with grief they must have
used that space in addition there was a
curtain that could be drawn behind the
in that space between the two curtains
and directly behind those two columns
there was a curtain space and that was
called a discovery space often things
could be revealed in that space you
could draw the curtain and reveal
something someone could emerge from that
space you could produce certain powerful
effects there and behind that space in
turn was a something known as the tiring
house a place where they would keep the
costumes and indeed in which the actors
could go and quickly change costumes
changes of costume are often quite
important in this theatre because it
marks as it does for us now significant
changes in the lives and fates of the
actors of the characters in the play you
might remember that Hamlet's ghost
appears in act 1 in full
armored with his beaver up that say his
facemask up and then when he returns to
the closet scene to the Queen's bedroom
he appears in his nightgown and that
marks an important change profound
change in the ghosts relation to the
action and the ghosts relation to the
characters and be perhaps in the fate of
the ghosts himself so in addition to
that there was yet another space that
the actors could use which were the the
gallery spaces behind the stage up above
that could be used for example as
balcony or as the ramparts of a castle
and other places in which you could have
an actor appear and you could also have
musicians appear there and for example
trumpeters or drummers who are marking
significant moments in the play so that
even though it's a by our standards an
extremely simple play space with nothing
in the way of are very very very little
let's not say not nothing but very
little in the way of equipment to
produce certain illusory effects
nonetheless there were lots of
possibilities that the playing companies
had including on even on on unusual
occasions probably some devices to
enable descents for example from up
above onto the stage but much much less
than we have and the the powerful sense
of entering in loo and illusion depended
as Shakespeare himself famously says at
the beginning of henry v on using the
imagination of the audience of
encouraging the audience to enter into
the fantasy and of course through
shakespeare's special gift of language
to conjure up whole worlds that are not
present before their eyes but we should
remember that in this theater when romeo
for example and then one of the most
famous scenes shakespeare every road is
at night under Juliet's window or in
Hamlet when the ghost appears at
midnight on the battlements you would be
standing in the afternoon in full Sun or
perhaps with the rain coming down and
you on a London afternoon and conjuring
up that world in your imagination